57 estados presentes y 2 fueron los
protagonistas
rusia y eeuu estuvieron en el foco de la
cumbre de la osce en estocolmo que se
celebró en el marco de las fuertes
tensiones entre ambas naciones en medio
de los temores de una eventual invasión
blinken fue claro en sus advertencias a
moscú
en la reunión con el ministro ruso de
asuntos exteriores fui muy claro en que
habrían graves consecuencias por la
agresión a ucrania
touraine
incluyendo como he dicho medidas
económicas de alto impacto que nos hemos
abstenido de tomar en el pasado
el jefe de la diplomacia estadounidense
reiteró que la otan apoya totalmente
evitar una crisis en ucrania como la
vivida en 2014 con la anexión de la
península de crimea rusia niega a buscar
una nueva confrontación pero las
ambiciones de kiev de ingresar a la
alianza militar le preocupan una
producción o infraestructura alliance
por el contrario la infraestructura
militar de la alianza se está acercando
a las fronteras de rusia en rumanía y
polonia se han desplegado sistemas de
defensa antimisiles que pueden usarse
para atacar es más pueden aparecer
cohetes unidenses de alcance intermedio
en territorio europeo la pesadilla de un
escenario de enfrentamiento militar está
regresando blinken aseguró que los
presidentes vladimir putin y joe biden
podrían dialogar pronto ucrania acusa a
rusia de reunir unos 90.000 soldados
cerca de su frontera y moscú a su vez
también critica la presencia de tropas
ucranianas en la zona el presidente
ucraniano volodymyr selenski señaló
recientemente al kremlin de querer
orquestar un golpe de estado en su
contra